Recently, a very famous British chemist, Ken Wade,
Kenneth Wade of the university of Durham died.
And he was also began his career here at the
university of Nottingham.
He was an undergraduate here and a research student and I found
his undergraduate record card here.
It gives his name and so on, on the front and on the back, it has his photo.
And it's quite an interesting thought.
If you're a student now watching this video, that's in 70 years,
time or 60 years time,
when you finish your career,
somebody may be looking at your record cards and finding out what you were
like when you were young.
Ken Wei was an inorganic chemist who spent most of his life
working on the element boron.
And he is one of the few chemists that I know that has actually
got his name into the literature.
There are a few people who get their names on elements Borum
[inaudible] and so on, but that only happens after people are dead.
Ken Wade has his name associated with a set of rules that
explain the shapes of a whole series of boron company. Ken.
Wade came up with this, his theory,
which is which he called polyhedral skeletal electron pair theory. Um,
but we tend to call them. I tend to go into my second year as a Colombian weeds,
right?
There are so many compounds in chemistry. It's often very confusing.
Why does this one have that shape? Why does that one have a different shape?
Can produce the set of rules that explained why a
particular type of boron compound adopted certain
shapes.
They allow us to, um, predict the structures of these things called borings,
these boron hydride compounds. Um, so this is kind of like the, the first one.
So this is, this is diapering. We've got these boron atoms here in black,
and then we've got these bridging hydrates. So we've got two of those. Okay.
And we've got four terminal hydrates. So it's like three it's like,
if I show you,
we've almost got two pH threes kind of coming together.
Okay. And they can make bigger structures like this,
which is Tetra Bori.
He came to this university in 1950.
He was an undergraduate here from 1951 to 1954.
So he finished as an undergraduate 60 years ago.
So it tells you the subjects that he studied at school,
it also tells you the name of his tutor,
who was the famous explosives lecturer BD saw.
And on the back is a rather fine photo of him.
He looked quite serious. Students wore ties in those.
And over here, it has his marks. And over here in the final year,
you can see they marked with Greek letters. Alpha was good,
then beaten, not so good. And gamma was terrible.
And here he got beat her for organic chemistry,
alpha minus for inorganic chemistry. And for physical,
he got beat to query.
Plus I've no idea what that means really means.
I think that the staff could put whatever number they like to this.
And over here it says that he did research with
Dr. Brynwood. And then after that,
he went to the university of Durham and he spent most of his career
in the university of Durham, which is in the Northeast of England,
not far from Newcastle, where I worked early on in my career.
And that's how I got to know Ken.
And he was an absolutely wonderful person in terms of supporting
younger researchers like me. So basically.
What they do is they given, um, the, the shapes that they adopt.
So what you do is you add up,
you take your pH unit and any of the hydroids that are leftover and you add them
up in each beach and it gives you two electrons to hold your cluster together.
Okay. And if we have missing vertices, that leads to open structures.
So we have close. So if they're all closed Nedo, which means nest,
I think that's like kind of slightly open than a rack. No.
Which is more open again, which I think comes from like spider, like cobweb. Um,
and, and so on. Um,
the nice thing about Wade's rules is by using this other theory called
[inaudible] theory, um,
we can interchange things like C H so carbon hydrogen units for BHS and
make carbon so mixed boron, carbon things. Um,
we can also use it for putting metals in instead.
So metal fragments can go in there, metallic borings. So wage rules, um,
covers a lot of, a lot of areas of main group chemistry. Certainly.
He also have his PhD thesis here.
You can see the title addition compounds of broader on tri chloride
and gallium tri chloride.
If I can summarize his thesis rather simply boron
tri chloride is a molecule with boron here and three fluorines and it's
a flat molecule, a planar molecule.
And it does boron does not have as many electrons as one would
like for a stable compound it's so-called electron deficient.
So it will react with compounds like ammonia that have spare
electrons.
So the ammonia here with a pair of electrons shown by the super
paper can interact with the boron to make a complex.
This is what he studied.
And you end up with a sort of complex like this,
where you have boron here and ammonia here and it squeaks.
Well, it didn't really, but you get the idea. So if we look in the thesis,
you can see it was lost borrowed from the library and the
27th of November, 1973.
And it was then taken out for this video, by my colleagues sometime on the
31st of March, 2014. So as far as we can see,
nobody has read this book for more than 40 years.
This is that kind of sad.
It's not really sad because all the important results will have been
published in papers. So this is more of the details.
What is interesting about this? There's of course the thesis was typed by hand.
There were no electric typewriters, no computers,
and the diagrams were drawn by hand and actually
paste it in of course you needed several copies of your thesis.
So you had to type it with a so-called
piece of carbon paper like this,
which you put between two sheets of paper. And then when you typed,
if you type very hard,
you could write something like four on tri chloride and all
being well, it would come out underneath often, not very bright.
This is the top copy of the thesis, which had to go into the library.
And the carbon copies were given out to the supervisor and
probably another copy to his parents because most students give a thesis to
their parents. And that's where we carbon copy our emails. Yes.
The interesting thing about Ken was that he began his
career as an experimental chemist,
but then later on in his career,
he became more of a theoretician.
This type of theoretical chemistry is extremely valuable
because it enables chemists doing their experiments to
understand their results.